this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
by the way you're [__] uh your
awesome hat matches your tattoos yeah
the camo does that's right that's right
so well done buddy can you see me
Brandon Brandon oh right here
dude that scared me that scared me that
scared me though because I was like
where the [__] is it don't do that again
because I freak out when you do that
Brandon Brandon oh God you got me again
scared me you imagine if JFK had one of
these on what the [__] dude like I
wouldn't have seen him okay
bro yep you're so ready for the zombie
apocalypse no my Ops listen Boomer that
means enemies oh my Ops Ops is that try
and shoot me in the head
Brandon right here
ah [__] that gives me such a boner
speaking of which I woke up with a rock
hard dong I did too I'm 56. I was like
Hey 40 I was like welcome buddy not bad
right 5 a.m must be all the Magnesium
I'm taking 5am rockety Hard Rock Kitty
hard how was the show like [__] Eddie
hard it was it was Eddie Bravo it was
Jeff dye it was Sam Tripoli that's a fun
group did you put the crew together for
the pride month or
I did I put them together for pride
month uh uh Eddie Eddie got up after
Jeff and I crushed it Eddie gets up he
had he brought his Jiu Jitsu buddies
he's always got those those people all
great guys always great crew Machado
guys and Eddie is great Higa Machado was
there
um Frank gorilla was there we had we had
the whole Venice it was great it was it
was packed it was a place called Venice
West and I think we should start I might
do a little residency there if I can get
you down there you had your basketball
game Tiger's basketball I'm [__]
Tuesday nights I get it you might have
to come you could have come at nine and
God would have thrown you right up I
would have got there right at nine
probably if I Rush down and those crowds
come to laugh those crowds come and Sam
Tripoli Sam's like this Sam's going
thank you this side of the room what the
[__] is going on with that side of the
room yeah and just killing them killing
them and then um and he goes sure I'll
talk about things I might even talk
about I might even use the word now I'm
a bad person but everybody's [__]
he just went off the thing of this band
that's all right
Venice yep yep the old stomper Stompers
yep and and Jeff had a uh Jeff had a hat
on a Giants San Francisco Giants hat
yeah a lady walked in very attractive
lady she said you're a Giants fan and he
goes I'm not really I mean I like
baseball teams and she he goes are you a
Giants fan she goes kind of and he goes
how come she goes I dated Barry Bonds
for a while and everybody stopped and
Jeff for someone said how's he doing
how's he how is he in bed compared to
other guys she goes epic he's epic he's
everything you think he's attractive
very attractive very attractive well he
has that famous voicemail go I know what
you need girl you need the ding ding
yeah yeah he's you need that she said
you need that ding ding so so what's his
name said Jeff said he was hated biased
by everybody in baseball everyone and
she said he's one of the she goes yeah
well he was one of the best men I've
ever met in my life and remains to so to
this day I was like damn oh he laid down
that dude hype she was defending
she goes he's funny he was saying
because you know he was in a video it
was great well no no no there's got
great guys that people love like Nolan
Ryan and Randy John stuff he was an
[__] an [__] but my thing about
Barry Bonds I followed a little bit
because
I think he won nine Golden Gloves
and of course he was home run leader
yeah and I know there's an asterisk I
understand oh no but back then everyone
had to ask everybody the pictures it
doesn't work because the pitcher is
pitching him we're just sausages thank
you thank you that's what they did back
then that's like that's like having an
asterisk next to Fedor or Rampage or the
Mark Coleman like whatever the case it's
like everybody was there was that
rules them the rules then the rules he's
part of the rules and I would also say I
don't know enough about baseball but I'm
going to make a statement tell me if I'm
accurate I don't know that steroids help
you with your Golden Gloves Fielding
fielding and throwing it might be making
you feel thrust it helps you it helps
you throwing it helps you not being so
tired
it helps you yeah so terrible hot take
right you think so
that doesn't help you so let me give you
because it helps you stay healthy so you
perform lives you have more strength
longer but having said that I would say
that Fielding is more skill based
whereas hitting is bat speed at that
level everyone's skill based of course
so at that level so if you have more
stamina in the eighth inning than the
guy who's not on it that's a huge
advantage of course and it's also
fueling the ball getting to a of of a
pop fly or whatever great baseball
player one of the greatest ever one of
the greatest to ever play the game maybe
the greatest in some ways no not the
greatest no no one says that but no he's
good not the greatest no hey calm down
great I know you met one of those
groupies last night but oh I I followed
it he's a great he's good he's a great
not good he's great he's great yeah not
one of the greatest though no no you
don't think he's top ten
um you could have that conversation is
what I'm trying yeah he was [__] good
yeah yeah so his daddy played yeah so so
I'm just saying that so what made him
great was that same thing that made
Nolan Ryan great same thing that made
Roger Clemens great you know these guys
were all they just had a crazy work
ethic again
steroids yeah
like Nolan Ryan wasn't on him like the
Cy Young wasn't on him Frank Frank robs
the one Mike Schmidt was in on him Roger
Clemens was on him uh Joe DiMaggio
definitely not on Mike Trout not on him
Greg Maddox dicey Kevin Ken Griffey not
on him he got didn't Ken Griffin don't
start that no he didn't get caught never
never don't I'll look it up after that
look got up and waste your time let me
ask you I know foreign
no issues besides [__] chicks keep
going Lou Gehrig nope just started the
disease Ted Williams no issues Ty Cobb
no issues Ty Cobb's issue he's played
with all whites right I think Aaron no
issues yeah Willie Mays zero issue
besides a giant dick Babe Ruth no issues
got a giant dick it's Willie Mays dude
that's how I know now now
um either way so hard to achieve that so
I've always been for me I always defend
greatness like I like whatever it takes
to be great that's a guy who did great
things and so I I got all costs
no matter what I'd be a bad I'd be I you
wouldn't call me
I'd be bad
I'm just I'm just not a good I'm not
good at enforcing you you and me saying
especially back in that era I don't do
[__] well I think when we talk about
like when they talk about John stuff I'm
like you're missing the point there with
Jon Jones greatest of all time Bar None
no doubt about it yeah especially with
the testing now still undefeated
um you know any of those guys when it
comes to football baseball basketball
don't give a [__] what they take yeah
well like Cherry Lance Armstrong I'll
argue with you like all of them did it
they had to go down to 15th right so
finally I didn't get busted correct so
it's part of the game but again Barry
Bonds similar to Lance Armstrong the
reason they got absolutely railroaded
they were not good people didn't like
them now I'm not saying they're not they
can't change when you're that
competitive Michael Jordan notoriously
known [__] yes Kobe Bryant tough to
play with correct but
those guys to be those Elite winners
yeah they don't they don't play nice
with us Roger Clemens wasn't I mean if
Roger Clemens was winning he was good if
he wasn't winning he's going to hit you
with a [__] ball yeah you know there
was a lot of that so a lot of these guys
weren't uh
I part of what made them so great was
that rattlesnake yeah they hated
everything yeah yeah they wanted
greatness that's Barry Boston and Lance
Armstrong Lance Armstrong if he didn't
railroad everybody and screw everybody
over right wouldn't be that big of a
deal that's right he went back on guys
bat on guys bad on the entire business
like he was also he was a dick before
that people people I remember I remember
the I think the leader in Spain at the
Tour de France said I have no respect
for him as a person this is before the
steroid stuff came out well no respect
him as a bike or not yeah he's always
been an [__] but as long as you've
known him on a bike he's been on
steroids always EPO all that stuff so
that's what that and that's why Barry
Bonds got the [__] railroad too he's
just No One's Gonna root for that game
he's such an [__] like he's saying
catch up with take a little break take a
break I want to talk to you about uh
when you've got drinks when you want to
serve drinks you want to mix drinks you
don't want a lot of artificial sugars
and the problem with all these cocktails
there's so much sugar dude that gives
you the hangover yeah but you know we're
drinking on calabas fighting fighting
this weekend June Saturday June
moonshine for the fam this for the team
listen it's it's made with real premium
ingredients unlike most alcoholic
beverages they're transparent about
every ingredient they put in their
products the canned cocktails have no
added sugar and are made with
ingredients you can pronounce how about
that they got the margarita pack four
different flavors they got spicy Mango
Tropical online they got passion fruit
vodka soda and classic vodka mule we
handed them out I had a party they were
a hit oh it's a hit everywhere my ties
tequila fans vodka rum and then if you
can't choose get the mix pack that's
what they sent me get a little bit of
everything tequila vodka rum best of all
doesn't leave you with that I just drank
a lot of sugar feeling that gives you
the hangover you get a nice light
brighter bud that's why they can be
found on over ten thousand stores across
the country it's available at all
retailers you're already visiting for
groceries and alcohol like Whole Foods
targets Ralph Vons Albertsons Krogers
Wegmans Total Wine BevMo Safeway and
more
and we have quite the offer at any store
you can buy one June shine package and
get the second for only a penny a penny
yeah it's like 7 12 to 20 bucks yeah I
recommend getting one of their
best-selling variety packs again that's
what I use it's a great way to try all
their tasty flavors go to June shine.com
fighter text them a photo of your
receipt the venmo you immediately crazy
it's that easy that's
j-u-n-e-s-h-i-n-e.com slash fighter yeah
June shine
here's the thing dude I want my nuts I
want lower net carbs I want the best fat
profile I want more monosaturated fats I
want I want to follow the Mediterranean
diet okay so I want more monosaturated
you want tasty nuts in your mouth dude
you want nut Rich rare Omega fatty acids
help me dude you need macadamia nuts
formerly known as the most expensive and
rarest nuts it's one percent of the
market they're hard to come by you think
they're only for the rich anymore thanks
to our friends at House of macadamias
they're changing all this farmer owned
90 plus Farms they own farmer owned they
make them easy for you guys to get
they're fresh they're harvested oh
they're delicious macadamia nut bars oh
they're nice they get creamy nut butters
for you they got cold pressed extra
virgin Macadamia Oil they got it all the
Mac how about the Macross the artificial
ingredients oh they're nice snack bars
how about that I like the white
chocolate you get the plain chocolate
the blueberry I like the plain chocolate
myself I
say we eat these every day every single
day yep and they never give away
discounts but they say you know what for
the firing kid fans let's do it for loon
time they're giving you guys a free box
of the 45 free box of 45 Macadamia snack
bars oh wow you get one of each flavor
they get a little mix it up for you so
you get the snack bars one of each
flavor for free when you visit House of
macadamias.com tfak plus 20 for your
entire order so you get the chocolate
covered macadamias you get the vanilla
ones let's get the raspberry one if
you're trying to lose weight they're
probably one of the best things period
on the planet for satiety where they
make you feel satiated you eat less
calories but because the fat profile you
feel like you you're not hungry anymore
they're so good for curbing your
appetite yeah if you're like a tasty
snack they're the go-to that's House of
academius.comtfak
because look at Jordan great with the
grace to ever do it [__] no all right
I had I I heard that about Jerry Rice
from a teammate of his who was like you
know if your own teammates if you if
you're if you're glowering and not
really talking to your own teammates I
don't know if this is true
and this guy played with them or yeah
you'd know this guy famous football
player but it was interesting he was
talking to somebody else and yeah be
careful too because those older heads
are haters too they are right yeah yeah
this guy was are you hidden this guy
this guy was greatness too though in his
own right
so it could have been Joe Montana this
guy was defense this guy was yeah
greatness and he was he was talking
about it and I was like it was just
interesting to me I was like huh yeah it
depends yeah yeah because someone like
Scottie Pippen hates on Jordan all the
time all the time oh yeah
that's so weird to me but I do think
that Jordan was tough to play with
everybody they say it I mean he was yeah
you like winning yeah what do you want
to do that's right yeah you can't have
it all
yeah well I mean so Jeremy Lin uh
Michael I mean uh uh what's his name um
Carmelo Anthony ran Jeremy linov no no
no no so so when uh Kobe Bryant was
playing with Jeremy Lin he goes I don't
want to play with him anymore I'm not
I'm not and he wouldn't get on the court
with him then he called his teammate I
think it was Rick Fox I can't remember
and he goes and then he called the coach
he goes I don't want him on the team
because I don't like the way he plays
he's not a winner and Jeremy Lin had a
breakdown you know it's like [__] up
but Jimmy Lynn had a tough go because
yeah and then when he went to New York
where he was stealing the Limelight that
was Carmela's issue Carmelo issue this
is what makes jokic they play tonight by
the way guarantee they win but jokish
plays tonight the difference between
Jokers don't care if he scores two
points as long as they win Carmelo is
fine if you lose if he gets 40. that's
the difference that's a big difference
so when Jeremy Lin came on board and
scoring like 30 points taking away
points from Carmelo Carmelo literally
bullied him he's like we gotta get this
guy out of here wow they started making
fun of him for being Asian like there's
a bad stuff yeah
weird they went over to China eventually
and you know
they ran them out yeah yeah yeah ran
them out wow remember the NBA wow I
didn't know that
who's a superstar for about three months
I bought his jersey
it's great I got it now
the worst absolutely not no well you
I'll find my Venice if you want yeah
nobody wants that Jersey do you remember
that uh the the player that accused him
of cultural appropriation because he did
yeah that was me Martin that was me and
then Lynn pointed out that he had
Chinese tattoos on his arm he's like
yeah
yeah he's like dude you have Chinese
right in your arm you don't see me
saying [__] yeah that's funny the whole
dread thing's so stupid yeah just style
okay Ultimate Fighter uh episode two
dropped last night I watched it this
morning it's better yeah you got a
little better like attention uh the
tension's fake but the because only the
house four weeks I don't hate somebody
that long but it's better but again I go
back to the they [__] up with the the
layouts versus the veteran Dominic it
wasn't even a fight seriously yeah and
Connor's like God damn it he has all the
young guy he's like all right well
they're not even com they're not
incompetitive in any facet this guy his
first so this this the the the the
veteran that he fought so he's fighting
a young kid he has like eight fights
maybe nine fights total was on Dana
White contention series lost his first
fight so now he's The Ultimate Fighter
that's the prospect the veteran was in
the UFC he found a guy named aldraine
Sterling ever heard of him went to
decision with that this is a guy yeah
yeah Cody Gibson he's a stud and then
you get and you're you're starting out
you're giving that guy as a as a
prospect like what I don't understand he
starches him what did he just knock him
out flying knee like he his distance is
good the guy tries to take him down he
just nullifies that and he's like okay
kid boom flying knee starts in the kid's
like yeah I tried my best and you know
like this these poor young prospects
like this isn't how it should go you
know I turned that cron Gracie fight off
I didn't watch it all that's different
that's completely different thing but
but with this it's like
I here's my thing with UFC no one put
much thought into this because if you're
gonna do veterans
you do all veterans because they have
all the experience here's here would be
my answer if we're in the marketing
pitch they go okay we'll do prospects
veterans I go I don't like that why
don't you like about it okay well these
veterans that none of them are a name
they they've had their goal at the UFC
didn't work out they had cut for
whatever reason if one of these veterans
wins The Ultimate Fighter then what do
we do with them because they already
have 20 30 fights some of them you tell
me they're gonna be world champions no
not a chance they can compete in the top
15 at 145 155 no not a chance not a
chance not a no no they'll have a prayer
so what are you gonna do with it why
don't they have a prayer they could have
gotten better no but no not a chance not
a chance look up how how old I think
that uh Gibson guys 35 and he's already
been in the UFC so you're telling me
he's 35. so you're telling me at his
skill level he's going to go in there
compete so we're not we don't have
anything with the rest of the top we
have nothing to root for but but he wins
and then it's like what do you well
first of all who are you going to talk
something you go of course but who are
you going to talk to her at least if you
have a young Prospect we expect them to
have some losses some challenges we
still root for him he does the fame from
the show these older guys okay yeah oh
okay
which ones you beat volkanovsky out of
you is is there is there anybody I'll
answer that sir is there anybody who's
young and a superstar not yet not on the
show yet maybe one you know comes
through but as of now it's just tough
against these against these older guys
yeah those older guys just and they have
tricks they just know stuff they've just
been there it's just experience it's
[__] up through these young guys yeah
these young guys think it's their you
know ticket to Wonka's chocolate factory
it's not dude
it's not it's not so they're so they're
heartbroken when they lose like you pull
you guys get set up
it's such a bummer
Connor wasn't at the Wayne's again
it wasn't no he has to happen in this
contract we don't have to be at the
lanes he's like I'll agree to it but I'm
not coming all the time it has to be
that way yeah and then Dana came out in
the press conference and said uh they're
like okay so when are you gonna announce
Chandler and Connor he's like it's not
to get these Wrangle these guys in we
have money like Connor yeah oh the
fight's not happening the fights you
think stuff to wringle these guys in he
looking like khabib you look at they get
money it's tough to get them to get
punched in the face it's like of course
it is though yeah I don't it's a good
thing for Connor
and the views on the first app the views
on the the first episode was 400 some
thousand which is half of what Conor's
last season did yeah so I don't think
it's a matter of Conor not having to
start power anymore I think it's more of
people just don't like this format I do
I didn't enjoy the first episode I like
the second one much better but I yeah I
don't think it's any knock on Conor I
just think it's
he's been partying with the with Rick
Ross I think recently nice okay so it's
kind of like what do you you know it's
not like he's in training camp or
anything and continues to party like
this
is he drinking though or is he I mean
looking he's doing everything bro yeah
he's doing Stout now look at him
and then you see Channel like his all
Chandler posts him training
like I I just don't I think they're
announced like Connor's not ready
they're feeling somebody else for him
Connor is at the club right now uh
Connor's still at the club and he weighs
189 pounds so this fight's not happening
it's not happening yeah but you never
heard that from Danny he's like it's
tough to Wrangle these guys because he
looked like he's doing he looks like
he's doing everything yeah Oh you mean
he looks like he's winning your life
like this is a good thing
who are those guys that's Rick Ross I
don't know this filler
that's beautiful but it's like yeah man
he is whatever 300 mil in the bank oh
yeah you mean it's tough to get this guy
to agree to a cage fight he's probably
one his whiskey he's already won yeah
he's done he's one
he's one
yeah I just don't see the show I and it
doesn't get bet the ratings don't go up
after the first episode they put all
that marketing into it
yeah it's on mainstream ESPN too yeah
like so it's not hard to find I record
it so I don't know how they calculate
like DVRs and stream streaming but you
watch any shows
I'm watching Game of Thrones again for
the fifth time yeah
nothing compares to that right now it's
so can you forget how good it is yeah
um what about uh you don't you I want to
see what you think of sex life it's more
for girls but I think you're the kind of
guy your last recommendation you gave me
yeah was this movie
dude Brian goes you got to see this you
like World War II I was like yes he goes
you guys see this so I go on Apple I I
can't rent it I buy it don't give an
option buy them I gotta buy this [__]
movie I love Nazi stuff I have my
mother-in-law and follow-on camera I
cook dinner everyone sits down halfway
through my mother-in-law who usually
like same stuff with me broke English
goes this is terrible and I go I don't
want to say anything because I invited
you guys over I went this would be so
bad I mean come on so stupid it's
Commando man this guy has gold the Nazis
Lost World War II they're X and out
right and he has gold and he's walking
they stop him
he goes on this Revenge path to kill
these Nazis it's so stupid
he gets shot stabbed he can't die he's
Immortal
the plane crashes he survives yeah he's
Immortal dude he's a legend you know
what the movie's about he refuses
nothing no imagine if he can Gloria
bastard no dude think of in glorious
bastards in the fight scene no listen
way worse done not as good I think but
two hours so good I think it was it was
so bad really I think it was so good
shot incredibly oh and he just is a
badass who just kills he's also you know
I like it why you like it because he's
70. that's the other thing he can't buy
he's 70 beating up these Nazis by the
way with tanks and bazoons by the way
that's why he liked it yeah he's out of
the way he's like this still got
something in the tank what is that what
the [__] are you doing he's all stiff
he's like
they hang him from a rope don't even say
that they literally hang for a row yeah
and then he's like
gets out then he's flying a plane to
track him down yeah that's right that
[__] the movie's so stupid there's no
history to it there's nothing there's no
contact it's just him Nazis we're
scorching the Finish Earth and he the
war was over they're getting out they
lost yeah he [__] exacted his revenge
and then he kills Nazis and they they
turn the tank around even though they're
told not to
and they they find them yeah and he
kills everything say get out of there
he's like no he's all he holds the
accent he's all old oh don't beat these
young guys don't do that I don't like
that it's just the whole thing was so
bad I know you like it because he's old
as well it's a good movie it was so bad
you don't understand Cinema it was so
bad
you know what the problem is too reality
TV shows no I really don't you do no
you're on Tick Tock right
I went on Tick Tock at 60 you're on two
no I'm not all the time you get your
facts from there dude I do not know
you're so stupid you're stupid man
you're a six-year-old detox shut up I am
not can you bring this up I sold on it I
didn't know she got this killer whale no
I don't get mine then she can't find it
I don't even have Tick Tock dude you
can't find it and then podcasts
you mean when I was at looking up oh
we're in the Caribbean
shut up dude you know when that happens
when I was like oh Brian says good it's
about Nazis and so everyone's all
excited about it and I buy it
like first 20 minutes I was like okay I
better picks up though and then like
you're an hour and I was like oh there
and I'm like looking for approval and
you can feel the pressure they don't
like it huh and then my I feel my uh
mother-in-law let's go I'm terrible
terrible and I go but we have to finish
it right and Steve Steve my
father-in-law goes I'm gonna kind of
have to worry this is a little bit off
subject but I'm gonna tell the story
that I probably never told before
because I don't want to sound mean
but um I'm gonna tell the story but
don't like and be respectful and don't
absolutely not no but but not the way
you've talked about so
I was single I was a young man I was
probably 22 I don't remember
and my friend hooked me up on a blind
date
with a gal
and he and his girlfriend said
I think we you'd like somebody we really
like her she's a friend of ours and
she's great
and I said great and they described her
she's curvy and blonde and I was like
all right you know here we go yeah pick
me up at six
and I I
get connected with her and then she says
pick me up
um meet me at my house
so
I get there there's a note on the front
door that says let yourself in this says
I started ready yeah right so that's
weird so I'm sitting in our living room
which is already weird and when I looked
up she's coming down the stairs but
she's she needs help with a cane and
with the banister
right and I'm and I immediately I'm like
but she's very unsteady this poor thing
sweetheart on study because of weight or
unsteady because of uh
you're a piece of [__] well and she was
it was rather she had a type of Ms that
was rather Advanced aggressive yeah and
it's Ms when their spine shaped like a
question mark your spine no that's
scoliosis is your spine uh spinal fluid
starts your spot something starts to
degenerate it's a nerve so this is make
a wish situation well I I just remember
this beautiful woman who was having a
real Health Challenge
and she came downstairs and we ended up
talking in her living room because she
was too tired to go to dinner yeah
because they get tired really yeah and
if so of course you know me I'm my
cousin has I'm a [__] empath
you know and I'm not gonna in any way
act like you're gonna sit there for four
hours I'm gonna sit there for four hours
and I'm gonna I'm gonna try to make this
date yeah nice first I start a podcast
the problem is I also know that this is
not gonna be a date I'm going to be able
to I'm not gonna be able to take this
date further well hold on beside besides
the laziness and the the No No the
disease I realize that this is a health
situation that she has to deal with
on such a deep level you shouldn't be
mad at her you should be mad at your
friends be like so give me a heads up so
[__] hey I want to said no but you
could have gave me a heads up so so I go
we talk for four hours it is what it is
we have a drink she can't drink
and I leave feeling bad about the world
about your life about her I want to be
okay the blue balls whatever it is
I call my [__] friend I go hey uh I
got a quick question for you do you mind
a heads up yeah I have to a heads up
like that that I am now in a position
where I I sure she likes me but did he
go like her but did he go uh we don't
want to tell you because then most guys
wouldn't go on the day with him like
yeah didn't know he goes it was a thing
but we knew you were the kind of guy who
wouldn't care well I don't in some ways
I do in others in terms of I don't know
what's gonna happen here she's got a
whole thing she's dealing with I feel
longevity I can't go into this
[__] lost my mind on the guy a little
heads up dude
that's sisu
sucked is walking down the stairs yeah
it's just not what I was ready for no
ready me for something
did you do anal
[Laughter]
I think of her I hope she's okay it was
a long time ago yeah it's tough that's a
tough one
come on man I mean yeah give me some
a heads up this idiot this is the same
idiot that [__] recommended me and my
girl watch a movie called let him have
it
you'll like it me and my girl watch it
recently it's about a dude in England
during the the second world war he gets
injured he gets a brain injury he gets a
brain injury it's based on a true story
watch this
watch this he gets a brain injury
because there's a there's a he gets
wounded in the war okay so now he gets
roped in by these guys who said let's go
rob a bank or something they go to rob a
bank right he forgets and he goes let
and he goes the guy's got a gun he goes
let him have it I mean let him have the
gun but the guy shoots him
so they say you said let her have it so
they sentence to death this is the movie
but that's in the first of 20 minutes
and the rest of the movies he's on death
row yeah there you go and then
he dies like that and that's the end of
the movie yeah my girl's like
and I'm sitting there like this I call
him up I'm like hey [__] face I wanted a
romantic movie with my girl he goes yeah
I know he was the same guy that hooked
you up he's a [__] [__] that guy
I need better friends
camera daddy don't do it man let's take
a break let's take a little break baby
let's talk supplements for a second
let's talk about brain nootropics let's
talk about increasing your memory
getting better cognitive function let's
talk about double blind studies where
they prove that this stuff works let's
talk about on it Alpha brains they've
sold over a million bottles and we give
you your money back if you don't see
results that's how confident they are in
this product you have the regular Alpha
Brain you have the Alpha Brain instant
Alpha Brain Black Label which I take I
got Alpha Brain Focus shot Alpha Brain
pre-workout to get your mind for the
fight companion Alpha Brain Black Label
daddy that's all I use money back
guaranteed if you don't absolutely love
it but you're going to so go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k you save ten percent off
everything all the Alpha Brain instant
Black Label Focus pre-workout also
protein creatine I swear vitamins
everything dude it's great streaming
Fitness workout devices steel Club
Macy's kettlebells Primal Bells 130 all
that stuff you get 10 sent off
especially the Alpha Brain go to
onnit.com f-a-t-k let's get back to the
program earthworm neck
did you see in uh in Glendale they tried
passing the uh the lgbqt SW whatever did
you see do you see they tried passing
the the curriculum stuff in the school
to see what the parents did well
Glendale Ryan Glendale oh you need
Armenians [__] around but but do you see
that it gets nice because over 500
showed up but antifa showed up and they
they you know they're instigators don't
[__] with Armenia so I think they're
about three like three to five Armenians
got arrested
but you [__] around you're gonna find
out he started messing with people's
kids especially the non-whites the
non-whites are like we don't even say
what you're trying to push this ain't
happening
still got passed you still got passed
though what are they trying to do with
this LGB LG tbq LG you know what that
stands what is it lesbian gay bi
transgender queer queer what's plus and
then the the binary all that stuff yeah
until everybody knows that dude yeah but
what is two Targets
what's 2s Plus
an equation anyone two plus two s plus
two Sexes plus
uh male female plus more no two Spirit
Plus so if you're two spirit it was the
Native American which is not true for uh
somebody who embodied uh like a
hermaphrodite somebody embodied male
that's a real thing yeah it is it is
yeah I mean those other cultures don't
get down with it dude right go back
um you always want to move it the Battle
of LGB instructor has been going ongoing
conflict United States communities
demand School Board limit discussion of
sexual orientation decision to ban a
book uh about pioneering gay figure
Harvey Milk garnered the attention of
California governor Gavin Newsom last
week after a school board president
accused the saint activist of being a
pedophile look I I don't think you
should be banning books Harvey Milk was
the mayor of Los Angeles or what was he
city council San Francisco
assassinated by another council member
yes um and so was the mayor at the time
they were both shot at the same time so
that that's part of History we should
teach it
you know I I think some of this stuff
gets kind of crazy my thing is some of
the kids of my son's school can't tie
their shoes hey if if they're under a
high school a little different they're a
little I guess they're a little more
educated a little more life experience
even that's young but under under eighth
grade unless they got everything checked
off I don't think we should be adding
more [__] for them to be confused that's
true Baba you know like is all your
history you're all set on the history of
America like the real history you're all
set on on your numbers you're all set in
math and science and art and all you're
Ace in that okay let's start looking
over here you start adding that in see
and you also talk about less than one
percent I know and when people go this
one doesn't work when the Liberals go
well why do you care it doesn't affect
you it does now because when you start
pushing it on the kids kids follow what
other kids do so if my kid too if my
kids best friends right if they go oh
our parents they're all about the lgbqt
what cool that's on them but what it
does is those parents push it on the
kids so if those kids go you know what
we're gonna chop our wieners off and
start wearing dresses my kid goes I
guess yeah all right yeah I guess that's
what we do well so it starts it starts
at home so when people go why do you
care don't infect you it's not your kid
I get that but that's gonna influence my
kid that's when I care I would say this
I have an 11 year old he's because of
the internet
because of the internet
you know he's so aware of everything he
knows gay he knows trans he knows queer
he knows all these things because it's
it's he's got an older sister
my daughter read a lot of fantasy novel
like a lot of uh uh uh anime and all
that [__] all that stuff so anime
but also
um she's attracted an octopus also um uh
like uh Percy
The Hobbit all that so when you read
those Lord of the Rings yeah Percy
Jackson when you're when you're in that
um when you're he's not but when you're
in that um oh no he's the in that realm
yeah you're in that realm there's
something called fandom
and with fandom they are like the people
that write uh actual blogs about it
right the additional stories so it's a
real community
in that Community there's a lot of queer
um there's a lot of queer activism like
there are a lot of artists and a lot of
writers who write queer characters there
are queer characters in the book so what
happens is kids who are 13 14 girls as
they're coming into the thing they start
exploring that on the internet they
start looking into it they they so
so they're educated children are
educating themselves in their own way
and I think that there's nothing wrong
with teaching gay rights the gay
experience in America which is part of
history when you do that as a question
when you start confusing children about
gender because boys and girls for the
vast majority and I'm talking about
99.5.0 99.9 of boys and girls have
enough to worry about their boys there
are some people that develop gender
dysphoria mostly men later on in life I
don't know what it is they should have a
safe space and be taken care of yeah but
I don't want to get into that when I
what I think that is a reasonable
criticism is to say you guys cannot take
my kindergartner and start telling him
or her that a girl or a boy is just a
feeling
is is when when you start imposing the
idea that there's really no there's no
there's no difference yeah you're lying
I don't agree with you but here's the
problem keep it out of my class correct
and it's okay to disagree and go well
I'm going based off science the way I
was born and raised I go based off
science this is science let kids arrive
what it is what what the the stuff
they're pushing on children's stuff like
it it's no different than religion I was
about so if you're if if he's Christian
you're Muslim you're an atheist yes if I
go Brian Jesus Christ is my Lord and
Savior
it's okay for you no he's not I don't
believe in God now if I go well hold on
dude you have to acknowledge it and you
go no but that's not my religion and I
go hold on Brian great point now now not
only do you have to acknowledge it I'm
going to educate your kids in school and
you go hold on dude I'm not buying into
this doesn't matter and keep this in
mind too the trans movement is a
religious movement correct there's no
difference it's a religious movement now
imagine if they push the same the same
agenda on religion so if they did
Christianity if they did so if they did
the Muslim religion schools and you went
well hold on we're we're Christian
doesn't matter
let's take it a step further if you even
deny that if you even say a man's a man
a woman is a woman if you say that there
are biological differences you you will
get censored you will get banned so this
is the other thing this this has become
a very aggressive fanatical correct
religious movement correct part of it
somebody said this on uh on who's our
guest on Rogan said
that when you when they the the when you
dead name somebody
what you're doing is they've had a
rebirth they've been reborn again they
have been born into their true self so
when you bring in the dead person you're
it's a religious it's it's heresy yeah
but you're so right that it's the trans
movement is no different religious it is
a religion it's not fair when we go uh
we don't really believe in that there
whoa dude how dare you well you have
rights too it's like yeah and and so
does you know the Jews have their
beliefs the Christians well I just
believe me personally I I you and I
would never I would never uh marginalize
a trans person if I saw somebody who was
trans getting beat up or bullied I
promise you that he'll come out yeah 100
but what I'm saying is this like I still
think personally that gender and biology
are are linked I believe that your
gender and biology are linked you can I
love gender bendering I love the idea
that you want to be you want to dress up
like a woman you want to do this all
good you want to be effeminate you want
I'm never gonna say no I love that about
our society I don't I don't love it I
don't love it but when you push it on me
but and then you have to say you have to
accept this it's like whoa hold on let
me I'm a uh a facts guy an Evidence guy
let me look at the evidence so for the
younger people that have gone through
that transition what what are the
results hold on they're more likely
commit suicide hold on the results are
actually negative no I'm not bored with
this well now if the results were
different and these people are getting
those procedures at a young age and
they're like they've gone Fortune 500
companies they've gone on to to be in
Hall of Fame Sports and I go man it kind
of makes sense the evidence shows and it
shows that it's not good it's not
healthy it's not a science it's been
hijacked by activists who are pretending
to be it yeah really it's a religious
cult I personally think we're a strong
country and a strong culture though
because we allow gay people and people
who are trans and all these differences
nobody's saying that right that's that
but that's that's where it gets hidden
when you start getting your kids you're
homophobic no no no I'm not I have some
friends who are gay do your thing and
gay it up suck all the dick I don't care
dressed in drag but when you force it on
children is when it becomes prom why do
you care educate kids and what you
consider to be a truth
when you say I don't feel comfortable
with that and you call me a bigot now we
have a problem because you're not
meeting me on and even then here's my
question where does it stop what makes
you guys Happy how far do we need to
indoctrinate this into schools where
does it stop everybody's trans the
radical left wants destruction correct
the radical f is not interested in
construction they're interested in
deconstruction and and destruction
the question is so you give them an inch
and this is why everyone's worried to
feel that just a little in that's how to
make you guys Happy how far does it go
and then wouldn't Christianity Islam uh
Jewish then we're like well hold on well
if we're going to educate about that
which is a religion why can't we educate
about what we believe we have children
and I think you're right and it's like
it's a diceye because again they're
never going to be happy ever so it
starts with this little small thing we
just want to we just want to acknowledge
gay pride month okay that's fine and
then next year okay well we just want a
few kids dress and drag okay it's
getting weird okay now we want a gay
parade and we want the kids involved in
whoa whoa what are we doing you're
homophobic whoa no I'm not man what are
you doing yeah that kid doesn't even
know his [__] ABCs right and you want
to You're Gonna confuse him about
chopping his dick off right and people
oh it's so extreme it's like we have to
go because we know where this is headed
yeah oh you get so extreme we're not
talking about cutting their dicks off no
we know how this ends we've seen it in
history before that's why we're trying
to stop it well a lot of things have a
lot of horrific things have been done in
the name of compassion and diversity and
equality and and that would be called
communism and I would say this that a
lot of um professors uh who have been
who have built the intellectual
scaffolding and architecture for this
movement our our um primarily Communists
and and at best socialists and
deconstructionists they don't live in a
world where they have to build a life
they live in a world where they can sit
on the outside and deconstruct them and
they don't have to deal with it and they
don't pay a price for being around zero
yeah so that's my problem now I'm all
about Pride mode I text Brian this
morning Hayes Pride months suck me yeah
yeah yeah I said be respectful dude it's
their month yep do your job I said do
you still have sugar in your mouth you
still have a little sugar in your mouth
from sitting on the couch in slippers
sucking Twizzlers while we were bringing
laughter to the mask the only reason
that doesn't work is I can't eat candy
right those days are gone oh you don't
usually because the old teeth are awful
yeah you haven't ate sugar what are you
gonna Invisalign bro never your two
friends really coming down huh no no I
look at yours hey you look no dude I
like this
those are great your two front teeth are
you're turning into an overgrown rabbit
and I said it and I don't give a [__]
I'll take it I'm gonna give him some
[__] carrots I'll take it because hey
you looking exactly the same group
[__] you must wolf you got your Lids
done you've got your hair you said this
dude you're saying surgery on my head
you've had plastic surgery twice three
well do you consider you consider in
design plastic surgery [__] you dude
I survived had technically three
procedures done your Lids you're here
your teeth my hair was a long time ago
and it didn't take hey winning comes out
of trans when are you gonna come out as
trans
what
that's I want you I'm not a very good
poster child for plastic surgery no it's
not working uh what's an x-ray plastic
surgery wise
you piece of [__] no you're probably
yellow done look I bet you'll Botox in
your forehead you know why I'd never get
a facelift you have to take your face
off as a as a man no no they they cut
here and pull it back Baba they cut here
I hate to tell you this
they cut the whole face off no not
anymore
it's not it's not the 90s movie with
John Travolta people look at me they
take the whole face off no no they cut
here dude that's why the cats have the
juicy ears no they cut their but they
cut everywhere
I don't think so not not in today's
technology everyone on there looks
exactly the same but no guy's got a
better chin
I mean kind of
yeah you can see it in the old yeah yeah
it's just old you can see it you don't
want to be a guy with that that guy's
better
he looks like he just got rest that's
all it is huh
he said you'll just look like you've
slept
hey go to the real old guy looks like
Brian with a mustache
hey hey that's hey but don't do anything
that's no hey but don't do anything
what did he think he got there why is I
so red he's 95. everyone's like dude you
look so much
old do you look so young right now the
old nose do I really like do like so
young
bro dude you look like you're in your
40s yeah he's like do I really hell yeah
dude yeah so worth it would you believe
I'm 86 years old best money ever spent
yes I would this guy get your money back
bro
this guy like eating just shut your
mouth you look younger dude also also
yeah uh just close your mouth dude
you're dirty you also you look that way
anyway just be old it's not going to get
better when you're that gray and just
the problem is every single person on
there is ugly
no one's attractive yeah this guy's cool
chin we're not talking about your type
which is a 54 year old white guy which
is clearly why you constantly hump me
with your eyes all they did with him is
fix his hair
yeah this combed his hair let's come
here real quick man his neck isn't as uh
this one looks pretty crazy
he looks like [__]
all around
[__] dude man oh man that's just a
change in lighting yeah that's huge he's
depressed he's just as depressed
hey at the end of the day there's not a
lot they can do for you there's not a
lot they can do for you
yeah the old chin starts to sag
yeah the the what they call them the
jowl that's a good job right there that
guy up there up top there top here yeah
hey Greta use my pointer oh yeah that's
my I don't have my [__] pointer see
he's got I like his jaw there yeah he
just screw out his beard dude no no he's
got he's got done with that well the
neck for sure the neck is good man yeah
I'd like to get my neck yeah oh that's
what you need to do next you know yeah
I'll neck my I'll get all your neck
looks like an earthworm
you're like segments I've noticed that
yeah don't say earthworm you piece of
[__] earthworm neck you [__] you got
earthworm gym [__] no I don't
you know you know earthworms have like
the lines in their bodies yep it's your
neck
it's like stretching yeah earthworm tell
you what one we met it wasn't that way
no I sure wasn't but I'm gray as [__]
it sure wasn't pal
yeah
but I'll tell you do you hear the big
follow the UFC 289 no
you're not doing companion
the card was already shitty
and now you're not doing companion I'm
sorry
why tell him is it dinner no fry it's
important the week of and we didn't go
to my birthday dinner oh yeah yeah I'm
gonna go yours when is yours no you're
supposed to take him yeah I'm taking the
earthworm neck
it will take us
there's a week ago man
well I gotta take you to dinner you're
the one
what do you mean I'm you're the one
always cancel no I said I can't go well
you said all the three Tuesday planning
Brandon was like ah it's a bad night for
me I'm like all right I told you that
morning though
I know dude that morning don't act like
it yeah but it's a stand-up spot
huh but she says spot we'll do a million
spots yeah I know companion
week off
earthworm neck it's [__] Wednesday
dude you got time and I'll figure it out
card already sucks cocked yeah what do
you got Jen
all right let's start off with this
before this I just wanted to shout out
Jesse Butler the guy that fought Jim
Miller big fan of the show just a
mustache so this badass Jesse Butler he
fought Jim Miller on a two-day notice he
was supposed to fight somebody else the
guy fell out and then they put in uh
Butler so he fights uh Jim Miller he
hits starch he ate a left hook but you
know it's still doing the damn thing
yeah
wow
it was a really bad knockout tube so
Jesse Butler lost fast knocked out his
career big firing kid fan shout out to
uh Jesse Bell keep your head up dude
nothing of dude there's no shame getting
knocked out by Jim Miller and [__] that
fast on a two-day fast two day notice
too badass shout out to that dude so
he's been watching every episode since
day one thanks Jesse you're the man
buddy sorry about Brunswick what else
you got Jim it's thick and ready uh we
just recently put a uh we recently
covered a story about some tourists
trying to touch a bison or just do a
selfie this guy is harassing bears
play this video real quick cool
leave the door open
[Laughter]
I want that bear to turn around I know
right and then he takes his shirt off
[Laughter]
can you imagine if that was your friend
I'm like what are you doing man
yeah he would get his pants if that bear
was like hold on I got time today dude
I'm starving and I eat tools for
breakfast legit eat tools you do that
too the wrong Grizzly are those that's a
black bear though
he's doing smaller ones with the first
one in Grizzly though it kind of looked
like it he's a brown bear for sure bears
do run from you he's small yeah they're
scared in general like what is this guy
doing the problem from his terrible
haircut why is he doing this
uh the gram are you kidding me with this
girl is that is that real this is real
but that Buffalo or that bison whatever
it looks like it's so sleepy he's so
tired like uh just get your picture
[__] and move on
she's so lucky look at his horn yeah
she's so lucky she fixes her hair nice
smile yes she looks like she's
attractive for sure she's so dumb
it just drives me nuts
that thing is gonna be like hey get out
of here
also the way she's holding camera can't
even see the it looks like she's just
you can't even see them she stays there
what kneel down girl get get in his
grill I don't get it I don't get it
either I do not get it well he's gonna
be investigated hopefully it uh charges
pressed on him because it is illegal to
do that to run at the Bears to taunt
them
really yeah crowd work on the base
facing criminal charges for disturbing
Wildlife fish and wildlife service
doesn't [__] around with us no dude oh
they're all they don't they're like hey
how about how would you like what kind
of how would you like a crazy fine
so when you kill the wrong when you
think you don't have the tag if you get
caught poaching oh oh screws they're
like I'll tell you what we're gonna take
your truck they look all into it we're
gonna take all your guns suspended for
years too you can't hunt like even elk
like when I was in Montana there's a
moose not properly like getting somebody
in the shooter he's like oh you know
hard as you get a Moose tag I'm like
yeah but he's not probably can't kill
him he's like you know screwed we'd be
like really he's like yeah dude you
can't touch those things
100 percent
and that's a good thing
uh so Brennan you might know more about
this but yeah I do too kill her popping
in Portland potentially because I mean
75 miles within each other like six
different people they're all killed the
same
remains all found 75 miles in Portland
Portland has big enough problems already
are these all homeless women or
something some were one's a caveman this
one I don't get why
yeah that picture is just insane the
drawing yeah
that sounds like there's a serial killer
yes
um let's see so this one's a homeless
woman
but then other ones look kind of normal
like these look normal but where did he
where did he find them though
State Park I know that one was in a
state park I always get you in the Parks
man
and this one was just trippy it's a
sketch that could be anybody well she
might have been decomposed that could be
Theo that could be chin that's how you
feeling chewing had a baby oh yeah it
could be anybody possibly Native
American
Alaska native Alaska with tattoos of
music notes on her chest a seated boot
on her right shoulder blade it sounds
like these are this was in a barn that
were uh homeless when I was in Portland
to see the
level of homeless and Drug First Team
all homeless out there dude it's so
crazy you're talking about deep
psychosis it's nice to end up dying you
can't believe they're alive just walking
around see what happened in San
Francisco they're trying to put money
into it so it keeps getting the bad name
of homeless and like all the crime and
then it came out this guy who's been in
he owns two buildings like huge
buildings back-to-back was like I'm out
gave up the gave up the building sold
them was like I'm out it's too bad here
wow
well Portland is having so many problems
when you go there Portland San Fran
that's all they have it's the worst
thing about the homeless oh yeah I mean
Portland's Gotham City when Bane took
over yeah it's just and there's there's
like no hope either it's not well they
it's so funny because now they have
these Outreach you're not allowed to
camp now they have they call them
unhoused campers they call them they're
they call them on house Campers or uh
people without house campers they call
them campers well I'm a camper and they
call you them unhoused neighbors the
unhoused yeah
uh the people without homes sounds like
a graphic novel oh snaps I don't know
anything shots this to me so when I was
playing for CU we're in the Big 12 it's
a big deal they left and went to Pac-12
they never had the infrastructure the
athletes it's a Passing League so now it
looks like they're headed back to Big 12
which is a big deal well I don't
understand no I don't understand
anything Colorado Buffaloes so what's
believe in Pac-12 so pack 12 Pacific
Pacific 12 so that's like USC UCLA
Oregon uh not as good athletes you're
saying it's different it's different so
big 12 was notoriously known you're
talking about not not anymore but when I
played timeout Texas Oklahoma Oklahoma
State Kansas Kansas state Missouri and
then uh CU but now like the teams have
they've just it's all over the place now
but Pac-12 is more
up it's like a Passing League Arizona
Arizona State uh UCLA USC but when you
switch those conferences you got to
build the team for this Passing League
it's just what they like the athletes
the receivers the the it's not as much
defense Big 12 was like hard dose
football big boys athletic big boys
multiple Heisman Trophy winners came out
of those years but it's just a tougher
more physical game and then we just
switch conferences well you're designed
to oh hang on Miami be part of the Big
12 no no not even close uh Miami would
be uh uh ACC Atlantic Coast Conference
okay so it just depends on where they
are sec's the the big boy but it's
Nebraska would be big B12 yes just big I
think the rest might be like Big Ten now
they're all over the place now and it
was word that uh the no Colorado's gonna
go the Big Ten but thank God they're not
because you gotta remember the
recruiting
and then also the families who travel
the game so if so if you're in you know
the ACC and you're playing Miami and
[__] you know all these other teams
to travel is the nightmare the TV right
is like the nightmare so it's good
they're gonna go back to Big 12. so if
you play um the Big 12 Football like
that what how much of your day at
college is spent on football
how many hours I mean you know how many
practices two a day uh in Camp two a day
but then during the like regular season
when you're in school you'd have you
know maybe film in the morning practice
so two a day still yeah and then in
between that you're going to classes
does it say when it's gonna be happen
chin it says reportedly so I'm not sure
bacon nothing becomes official until the
Pac-12 gets their TV deal financed but
now multiple sort of tests tonight Bob
some beer down we'll move to the Big 12
don't wear it on the youth Sun Devils
interesting
it's a good thing if they go back there
okay so this story we might have brought
it up a while ago this but this is from
2019 and x-shares deputy uh she was
attacked by some guy with schizophrenia
but she was reporting to a like a
domestic violence type call so she tried
to arrest this guy at a house but
there's also a woman there holding a
knife but she tried to get this guy's
hands behind his back
and then let me just play this video
because it's so it's longer I'll cut it
out but so you guys have a better idea
what this is and I'm I'm actually
shocked about this and this is a new
thing going on no so this 2019 but she
left I think she's suing now or
something the deputy no the reason why
this thing is because the guy got off
scot-free it has more on the defense is
that Cleveland from the Family Guy
it's right
that's the deputy
disbelief
May suffered several injuries Megan
McCarthy has the biggest eyelashes in
California
you lock me up am I right go away the
key girl guilty am I right guilty girl
toss me in the cruiser reporting party
and she has a knife in her hand I she's
very pretty yeah
just tell him you know relax it's okay
what's going on just to pat down his
pockets for weapons
set him off
and shot it I like shot the hurt took
her
scot-free and then look at the you'll
see in a second here this is California
that's when other deputies respond shoot
the suspect and take him into custody
they shot him in the incident caught on
camera pulling a gun at him
light guy's hair is terrible what are
all these characters that's the D.A you
got a Facebook
he argued that the suspect was not
shooting at her what exactly where she
went was due so and we know where he
fired because there's a bullet hole he's
just doing his job
it's insane
he's a bad shot
and battery on a peace officer well to
find someone guilty shot there the law
says the person being assaulted had to
be lawfully performing their duties
while it might sound like just a
technicality to some Moline argues the
deputy did not have reasonable suspicion
that your instructions wow
you have to have a reasonable suspicion
that they're involved in criminal
activity and in this case the issue was
was the initial Detention of Mr young
legal if it's not that he's not guilty
no man he could punch her 100 times and
it wouldn't matter what I don't get this
at all I see a situation where there's a
woman in such fear of her life she is
armed with a knife we should bring her
in figure it out yeah maybe he has a
weapon Ari young was found guilty of
negligent discharge of a firearm check
this out
bars long enough to serve that sentence
was set free wow she medically retired
from the Department
she has an only fans account
Nick Davis the number one customer
how stupid there's like the craziest kid
it's insane like he took the gun started
shooting
like that thing happens I guess he's
doing his job the piece of [__] but he's
just doing his job and they're finding
technicalities that's his job to find
those this is also why though when you
always have backup when you have a woman
there who's that probably weighs 120.
you're trying to they came real fast
though I mean huh they came for the cops
came fast you want to wait for backup a
lot of times yes either way I guess
you're being [__] have your taser
ready it sounded like she had her gun
ready he [__] her up and took it and
then shot at her well that's why you
always have to train
God I hope she goes if I go to the
ground I hope she's okay let's check up
to and follow up all right if we can
donate in any way
um the sign in you better not disappear
again Brendan I'm here ah
this one's tough to watch but I think
it's good to show this though people
don't do this same mistake this hurts
this father was trying to catch a foul
ball
and then I'll just show you what happens
he was he was holding his son oh no
that's not good I don't like this I
don't like it either but
if anyone's in this position don't run
with your son
and then
get his head so bad on the back of his
head yeah damn dad get more athletic
yeah this little boy they said the sun's
fine but you know it's that hard it's
weird you see more kids that have CT and
maybe they do but my my especially tiger
hit his head all the time I mean Boston
like just running each other I'm like
how they're like battling ramps like how
do you do not have CTO because they're
you know their bones are yeah they're
green they're like uh like green trees
yeah I mean like you know a branch is
green when it's yeah it can bend a
little bit well you know their skulls
don't form all the way so it's pretty
flexible there's some some give there
[__] man little kids be [__] their
domes I know they do they can't help it
they should be running the walls and
[__] yeah like little Rams like how do
you guys not have CT now they might
though right yeah well you know I think
everyone has a splash of it right it's
growing yeah you know UFC star Israel
understanding chokes out Logan Paul
during sparring oh we saw it you would
click on that you would please don't
yeah there's a strain together yeah I
mean that that's pretty obvious that
what happened so this is more for Brian
this girl went viral because of I'll
just play it for you
that's actually her she's Jack built
like Brock Lesnar there's her again
let's see what's going on she's it's
she's a pretty girl
strong gal yeah yeah I bet she's small
she's as big as her biceps are she's not
being a big girl short arms yeah she's
so pretty there right and then she takes
her up like okay this is some big hands
and some between us I like her there let
me take your shirt off you get rock hard
now it's a little uh too meaty a little
slightly you're too lying the ass for
that she does look strong though yeah
she's a pretty gal though yeah now that
picture there with the booty I'm drawn
to the legs and ass like that
right
any other General [__] she's an athletic
strong that's not Herbie I'm a different
person but I'm a big fan of that of ass
of just that whole body yeah yeah
everybody is yeah the hot chick a lot of
guys like this little too much for me I
have friends I don't I think so man I'm
always like really we have friends who
are celebrating this month who don't
like that well that's what that one I'm
with you buddy yeah
athletic attractive girl yeah what's
wrong with your friends well the guys
are like our shoulders are too broad I'm
like not so they're probably soft guys
it's fantastic though yeah what's this
so I guess one of the heads of PETA
started making statements about Pete
Davidson buying a brand new dog because
you know obviously they want them to
adopt dogs or whatever and then God damn
dog's cute as [__] yeah and it became
like you know started showing up in
articles you know how how could uh P
Davidson do this and then he left this
voicemail for how could Pete Davidson
buy a new new dog it's so yeah why are
there taking Pete you know
I just want to let you know I'm severely
allergic to dogs so I have to get a
specific degree I'm only none of us to
cast the food
my mom
's two years old died a week from here
and were all success so I had to get a
specific job
to research
Supreme news stories for people because
you're a boring confidence
[Music]
good for him
good for him good for him is right yeah
good for him I approve that's his new
girl I approve of heat damage but yeah
that's a cute little yeah so a Cavapoo
that's a cute I want a Cavapoo now I'm
gonna get a Cavapoo instead of the
receiver [__] Pita not for you bud my
my girl my girl too expensive not for
you what too expensive really you're
gonna you're the poor person dog get
that dog adopt a dog right
that's not for you
you're making me annoyed now that's nice
for you you're not you're not Pete
Davidson money right
well how much do you think that costs a
million dollars you [__] I don't know
it's for everybody
I did watch Pete Davidson spend forty
thousand dollars on Pokemon cards one
time yeah yeah yeah he's Bank Rich dudes
do that this is for Brennan I don't know
exactly what this is for but I guess he
was climbing this
that's amazing look at how good he looks
I wonder why you decided to climb the
hair how high he said that he was with a
tick tocker as well and someone's taking
pictures but I don't know what the
reasoning is before this doing it for
the tick tock hey you're so famous you
don't need to do this Jared for looks
likes
how high up is it I mean it's not crazy
high but that's pretty hard I would be
freaked out about that oh my chin this
is stupid no it's not look dude oh tell
me it's not high if you fell down from
there you'd be completely fine chin it's
as high as her Studio do you agree do
you right do you agree on your back and
be fine look
oh get the window this isn't a story
they were zooming in I was like man is
he like us guys no remember they zoom
out if you if you only listen to this
he's a body
I'm gonna challenge you can climb he's
one and a half people think if he
climbed the side of a Pizza Hut
these two people high so he's almost at
the second top right you know what he is
two people
he's about as high as a basketball hoop
you know when a guy dunks a basketball
and you're like man I hope he doesn't
fall I would say he's one person he's he
was in the top though he was there
that's kind of high he was there his
feet are there but there he's about he's
about 12 feet in here he would fall this
fast
you become believe he'd survive he'd be
you know what he wouldn't even roll his
angle wow if I'm Jared let him like
don't zoom out just let him see I'm
climbing this guy when chewing jingle oh
man well that guy can reach his feet
that guy can touch it yeah yeah
so yeah he's a daredevil man
wow my boy wild it's like that's that's
all they should post holy [__] he's
trying to climb a building
well there you go yeah it's not very
risky there and I think that's pretty
much it oh the Iron Sheik passed away
today I don't know if you guys heard in
the Olympics
I didn't know that an Iranian Olympic or
for the Iranian Olympic team 81. it's a
good run
pretty good run especially coming from
those old days and then Georgie was
showing me like videos of him on the
Howard Stern Show yeah Marty Lane would
impersonate like Macho Man or Hulk Hogan
and just get this guy riled be a legend
yeah amazing Iron cheek was a legend he
was great on Twitter too
that's a bummer a mustache this is the
last one I guess because
you worked with him Brian before I never
worked with him all right never mind
same show oh which was uh I never met
him oh okay okay never mind then he was
uh he had brain surgery what was his
what was it for
he couldn't walk around or something I
forgot what it was yeah
anywho
I wish we had some better ones but
that's it that's good it was a good
podcast I think I won that one all right
guys
God bless and um
I'm at Comedy Works in Denver coming to
my city in the month June 29 June 30
June July 1st
um yeah oh you had the blue Rod at LOL
in July I got to change that I'm there
in August now
will you go in the Blue Room the room
would you like my boys
my guy that'll be fun that'll be great
top best fight campaign this Saturday no
Brian Brian's a [__] uh this Saturday
UFC 289 is going down you got the Schmo
you got our boy Mata ryza you got Paulie
Shore and myself tune in that's mpm live
UFC 289 calabas fight command thick boy
YouTube only okay kids love you enjoy
the month